des médecins qui défilent dans la rue ce
n'est pas un spectacle courant il était
pourtant plusieurs milliers cet après
midi à paris des invalides à la gare
montparnasse 20% des cabinets étaient
par ailleurs fermés à paris et près de
la moitié en province
à l'origine de la grogne des médecins le
régime conventionnel vous connaissez le
principe chaque médecin s'engage à
respecter les tarifs d'honoraires fixé
par leur syndicat et par la sécurité
sociale
or les médecins voudraient que ses
honoraires soient renégociés dans le
sens de la hausse bien sûr mais le
ministre de la santé ne l'entend pas de
cette oreille
je pense que ce qui est fait mais c'est
sain c'est d'assister à cette
démographie galopante dans leur
profession qui dans laquelle ils ont
conscience qu'ils vont être beaucoup
plus nombreux d'ici quelques années et
qui peuvent crainte il put elles peuvent
craindre dans ces conditions que la
concurrence soit difficile que certains
soit amené à exercer dans une zone ont
des modes d'activités qu'ils soient pas
aussi satisfaisante maintenant et
surtout que compte tenu de l'impact que
l'acte médical assure à siph le cas
social les pouvoirs publics soient
amenés à prendre certaines mesures non
pas du tout nationalisation mais
simplement de restriction du pouvoir
d'achat car s'il y a le double de
médecins qui sont en activité d'ici
quelques années
est-ce que la sécurité sociale pourra
supporter le double dames